well first tonight a British Israeli
family were trapped for 9 hours with a
10-year-old baby as Hamas terrorists
burned down their house and ransacked
their town close to the Gaza border
Deborah minz originally from ronford and
Essex hid in the tiny room with her
grandson Kai and his parents Amy and uel
lean I'm pleased to say they're all safe
and well now and that all of them now
join me live well welcome to all of you
thank you so much I can't even imagine
what you've been through so let me say
that off the the top of this interview
um Deborah let me start with you um for
you this must have been like a nightmare
happening in real
time um yeah even as I look back I find
it very hard to believe that I was
actually
there um yeah it's something in my
wildest dreams I I never thought would
would
happen and Deborah tell just tell the
audience
as best you can remember exactly what
did
happen first of all I want to apologize
that we're cing because of smoking
Elation so that's the first thing I want
to say we were woken up about 6 6:30 and
I'm not 100% on timing it was about 6
6:30 there was a red siren alert my
daughter and her husband and the baby
were sleeping in the secure room bunker
I suppose you'd call it with a still
door and she screamed at me mom mom come
there's a a siren so I picked myself up
out of bed my little dog wouldn't come
with me he was afraid we picked up the
big dog and off I went into the room we
closed the door now this room is to
protect for Rock from Rockets it's a a
concrete
reinforced room with a still door and a
steel
window um after about an hour hour MH we
start we heard gunfire
outside and we realized it it took us
time but eventually we realized that we
were under attack my daughter has
security cameras in her tiny little
house as she looks on her phone and she
screams at me Mom Mom the terrorists are
in the house they entered the
house and she and her husband with all
their might came the handle of the still
door upright so this isn't a door that
locks from inside and that's it it's a
door to protect you from Rockets not
from in in Invaders and
Intruders and they couldn't get us out
they were shooting at the door so they
set fire to the house they switched off
the electricity so we lost the we lost
camera
vision and the the smoke started coming
under the still door into the little
very small room where we
were because there was no electricity
there was no air and the window was
closed and from that point we we knew
yeah that's their house we we knew we
were not going to
survive
but from the grace of God I I don't know
how every time we believed that the
terrorists were not around the house
that they've gone to another house we
opened the window we picked the baby up
we put the baby on the window sill we
all got some fresh
air heard the terrorists threw the baby
on the bed closed the still window held
the door and we did this for about six
hours the room was completely filled
with smoke thick black
so
um during this time well very early when
they first started the the fire I think
the worst thing was we heard my little
dog scream but scream as she burned to
death and I I think I pretty much gave
up after that but for the sake of the
baby you you you try yeah and and then
when we
heard both the kids were on the phone
once Rio to his brother Amy to the phone
by Brigade but they couldn't get to us
they just couldn't get through the
roads and six hours in Smoke pretty much
nine hours from when it started we heard
Hebrew
outside and gunfire and more Hebrew and
then somebody called out Orel and we
said we're here we're here and the Army
came secured the house and got us out
through the
window obviously the baby first we were
taken to an underground shelter where
other people soon followed but we heard
horrible stories of other people being
shot and
disappearing and eventually because
still the ambulances couldn't get in and
we'd all been in a fire we were taken by
by the Army to the hospital which was
well over an hour away and my daughter
and her husband and baby Kai
we release today only today and today is
our reunion I was released on Saturday
night they decided I was okay it's uh
Deborah let me just say Deborah it's you
tell that story it's making my spine
chill listening to what you've just said
um and I'm just so glad that all of you
are still alive let me let me come to
you uh Amy I mean you must feel
unbelievably fortunate to still be alive
given what you now know was happening
all over the place to other
people yeah I mean uh honestly don't
know how he survived how Kai a 10day old
baby
survived um I guess is you know you find
the strength to uh to just protect your
family protect
yourself um and we just did what we we
in our instincts told us to do
um my husband just uh stood by the
window and every time he could he opened
it and we as my mother said we put the
baby uh on the window ledge and try to
give him as much fresh air as possible I
mean he was coughing us up just black
spit and and S and uh and after being so
many hours in Smoke and we literally
can't really see you or or anything uh
on the video cuz our eyes are burnt um
hopefully uh will'll get better as the
doctor said it should get
easier
um uh breathing troubles um loads of
medications but um yeah but we survived
and so did I mean it's miraculous that
you've survived and particularly with
this tiny baby uh Oriel let me ask you
when this was going on what when you
realized afterwards the scale of what
had been happening what is what is your
response to
this actually I can't believe that we
were caught in this situation I hope
that
um people responsible will give some
answers because I I grew up in this area
since I was 10 years old we were used
to I mean it's awful to say but I'm used
to to Rockets to the sirens
to to running to the bomb shelter from
time to time because after all these
years it became the reality where I live
but this what happened to us this
Saturday was in a whole other scale and
honestly I
didn't ever believe that we will go
through something like this it was
something else never never was something
like that
I think since Israel state was founded
you know I mean this is the worst this
is the worst Slaughter of predominantly
Jewish people since the Holocaust I mean
there's no other way to describe this
nearly 900 people or more now apparently
uh were killed in this and it's ongoing
um do you fear now let me ask you Amy
this do you fear that this is now going
to be a a raging War for some time to
come and what will you do as a
family
um well I honestly don't know how to
answer that I mean I I hope we'll get
through
this um I hope it won't get any
worse um we just uh are trying now to
figure out what's what's next for us and
where we going to live for I know the
next uh weeks or months
year um we literally just lost
everything um I mean I'm glad to say my
my dog managed to escape the safe room
because we weren't allowed to take her
with us she somehow managed to escape
and survive and she was found and
brought to us um so I am happy about
that um my dog not so lucky no I'm so
sad what was what was your dog's name
Deborah Nikky we had big ears like
Mickey Mouse and what what was Mickey's
breed um sort of like a little miniature
Doberman pin that bed a lot and slept by
my feet here he is that's Micky I'm so
sorry about about Mickey I'm so sorry um
about everything that's happened to you
uh I just want to say to all three of
you thank you for taking the the time
and trouble to speak to me in such uh
open and graphic manner I think you
really brought it home to people what it
must have been like utterly terrifying
buing I'm so glad you're all still alive
I'm glad that little Kai's okay and
you've had the treatment you need and I
wish you all the very best in rebuilding
your lies because like you say
everything's gone up right you have
nothing um but I wish you all the very
best and thank you for joining me just
mention something please yes that we
there is a g fundme set up to help Amy
and Orel rebuild
lives um I don't know how I'm supposed
to don't worry I I'll tell you what I'll
do Deborah I will tweet that and I've
got uh over 8 million Twitter followers
so I'll make sure that we tweet that out
so people can try and help you
okay your producer thank you very very
much for having much okay thank you all
very much I wish you all the very best
and thank you again for joining me thank
you thank
you quite extraordinary account there
from people who are just very lucky to
be
alive